the secretary of health and human
services says the covet 19 vaccine will
be safe and the process to distribute
the vaccine
will move quickly the i-team's vanessa
murphy interviewed the secretary
who is also chairman of president
trump's covet 19 task force
vanessa now joins us live with more
brian i asked secretary azar how much of
the vaccine nevada will get and when we
will get it he didn't provide an amount
or
date but he says the process is moving
quickly and the amount distributed
is based on population nevada has about
three million people so
it's a smaller state he also insists the
vaccine is safe and because of
operation warp speed in his words
there will be brighter days ahead
it's no secret governor sisilek and
president trump
have clashed what would you say to
people who think
politics could affect this or people who
may not trust the trump administration
or the vaccine
in that it moved so fast well politics
has and will play no role whatsoever in
the consideration development or
approval of our therapeutics or vaccines
there are over five separate steps and
independent checks in the process
i asked secretary azar whether the trump
administration could have provided
better guidance
and done more to save lives his answer
they've provided countless guidance and
advice i also asked what advice he would
offer for nevada specifically to get the
virus under control
considering the state's economy heavily
relies on tourism
and the first shutdown did help reduce
numbers but also devastated the state's
economy
he points to what we've been hearing for
months social distancing wearing a face
covering wash your hands
we also discussed thanksgiving he says
part of the problem is people have let
their guards down
and that should not happen over the
holiday and he also points to some data
from the cdc
he says if two people wear masks and
they're even as close as
a meter apart it can reduce the viral
transmission by
seventy percent that is seven zero
percent reporting live vanessa murphy 8
news now